ich bin ein ich bin durch meine lieben
villiger und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge minecraft triple
das heißt ich spiele eine runde wert
wars eine runde super smash maps und
eine runde heiden sieg und ich bin schon
in der ersten runde etwas
ich würde erstmal wagen wir fangen an
direkt mit diesem mit dieser zweiten
folge triplepack die blöcke wie keine
anders das macht weil ich bin super gut
hab einen hut und bin kein lob und wir
beiden ihr letztes mal jump nicht
geschafft da war ein bluff verdammte
scheiße
nee nee nee das wichtigste ist erst mal
dass bättig wird das bett zb bei edwards
nie mit diesem normalen blöcken einbauen
sondern immer nur mit diesen anderen
stellen mit diesen entscheiden die sind
viel viel intensiver und breiter sein
und spielleiter was boni denn hierfür
eine wendeltreppe hoch finden dass
hierfür für niemand widme ich kenne
kennen die abgeführten das ja immer so
meine horror vision dass ich mich da
oben so lange bau- und dann ich werde
ich auf einmal einfach so abgeschossen
ich habe zwei und ist schon wieder gold
gespannt wir laufen schon wieder innere
in der pfalz das desto ich bin dein
teamkollege
ich bin überhaupt nicht abschießen ich
bin auch fünf vollidiot hatte habe ich
mich gerade erschrockene alter freunde
ist endlos ist es los es fängt an jetzt
sei jetzt geht es mir die art wie ludwig
weidner letzten folge minecraft triple
weil dinge und nicht gesehen habe die
ist wahrscheinlich nicht in der
beschreibung verlinkt sondern irgendwo
auf einem kanal ist die oma prozent ich
irgendwo zu finden
ich wollte florida ganz am anfang in
dieser folge wir kommen da so an und auf
einmal du vollidiot du brauchst nicht
unser letztes einfach mein typ einfach
ganz am anfang an oder ist er gestorben
ich glaube sogar er ist gestorben weil
unser bett zu früh abgebaut wurde und
alles mögliche war nicht so geil in der
letzten folge unser bett wird abgebaut
weil das so krank lautet seht ich wohl
eine kleine festung bei und bringt von
mogan fallhöhe der typ ist weg doch der
wird sich daran ein jungs hat jemand von
euch ich will eine kette diesen tag
schon wieder für ein kack stift was soll
denn diese kacke ein gott ich mit ihnen
irgendwelche irgendwie mal kämpfen aber
nicht
darin legt und spitzen gegenständen ich
glaube ich werde einfach mal mein ganzes
geld in die spanier dann irgendwie eine
ender perle holen oder oder diese schafe
mit dem tnt die einfach nichts bringen
aber unglaublich knuffig sind das ist so
krank ich bin team rot und wir sind noch
zu viert und nun auf team blau mit zwei
anderen leuten ist da ich glaube ich ich
mach das jetzt wirklich mal ich jetzt
irgend ein geiles altem papier vollidiot
kommst du nicht rüber wir mit meinen 1
in der reihe gerade noch lasse ich mir
jetzt ich habe nur noch einen typen ich
glaube jetzt einfach über aber man sieht
auf jeden fall schon mal bei minecraft
triple immer ich bin ein wundervoller
mitspielen einfach so spitz hat ich muss
gar nicht zu grün ich muss zu blau im
blau oder ist wir haben gewonnen und das
war die erste runde und das pathos und
jetzt kommen super smash palin ja immer
auch du bist ja so kacke in pvp und
alles mögliche deswegen freunde wenn ihr
kommentare seht wie nach dem motto
irgendwie sowas ja auch du bist ja sogar
doppel das macht keinen spass
zuzuschauen
bitte könnt ihr dann eventuell mal
darauf reagieren weil ich schaff das
zeitlich nicht mehr auf alle kommentare
einzugehen und zwar einfach dann
schreiben ich finds gerade lokon kraft
findet gerade irgendwie witzig werden
bank verdammte scheiße und behinderter
motto mach dich doch jetzt hier so da
mein google und jetzt bin ich im jubel
und jetzt bin ich hier und ich hab zwei
jugendlichen boden also mangels kurz zum
thema nochmal kurz zurück zu kommen
wittmann ich will ja nur taktik ging da
hinten steht
ich bin übrigens beide bei der einzige
noch viel leben hat um ein coupé
cabriolet weniger die also leute ja ich
weiß dass ich kein pvp bin aber ich
dachte mir dass das eventuell gerade
witzig ist weil ich einfach überhaupt
keine ahnung von pvp und von kämpfen hat
in minecraft und alles mögliche
deswegen nehme ich das trotzdem
auffällig einfach bock auf das spiel hat
und das nicht so gut kann aber ich finde
es witzig wenn ich das nicht so gut kann
aber ich bin ja gerade auch irgendwie
einer der besten und wie haben die welt
muss und auch schon immer und zwar nicht
wegen mir aber ich war im team was
gewonnen hat und jetzt ist hier alles
ruhig einfach alle tasten die ich
besitze ich habe nur noch ein leben ich
heiße konkret
ich dachte ich versäume und sabi und wer
genickt
ich muss weg nee nee
ich wurde dritter oder vierter online
opfer nannte kacke das war vor die kurze
runde
das war aber voll die kleine maddie
guckt euch mal die map an dies ja mal
mega klein um anja gut egal das was mir
super match und ich habe gesagt ich
nehme ich glaub ich bin gar nicht
richtig der fest am donnerstag
ich habe gesagt die erste runde die da
ist also quasi so ja egal ob gut oder
nicht
in der heide ziel glaube die ist total
anders aufgebaut als sonst und tschechen
nehmen wir denn irgendwie sowas total
schwieriges nehmen oder wollen einfach
anderes genommen
ich will da oben drauf irgendwie das
werk killer ich höre geschlagen oder ist
das feld der mehr drin steht ich gehe
einfach mit dem anderen crafting
tempolimit ich gehe einfach mit dem
crafting table mit immer anders
das ist super versteckt dass ein
crafting table ich gehe einfach hierhin
und dann merkt das keiner weil das ist
eigentlich ganz gut und bieten
ich hab doch crafting table ausgewählt
ich bin ein bieten block durch den jetzt
immerhin mein ganzes leuten durch den
kopf wenn ich da oben drauf könnten wir
schon nah ist
aber ich beobachte dass auch noch
sonstiger wohin man verlangte canet
kommen dass jetzt nicht jeder mann
wo kann ich denn in alter wo kann ich
mich denn validen sitzen hier kann ich
auch nicht
das kann doch nicht sein ich muss doch
wohl mal irgendwo nach oben gehörten ich
will nicht in hier rumlaufen und dir ich
gehe ich gerne aufs schiff genau und
kommt man hier noch mal reiten wo die da
an spannung pur meine lieben freunde das
doppische morlok am block oder gar
keinen sinn natürlich ist das blog ich
vollidiot das ist ein high damals ich
will dahin hat mich irgendwo ich hier
niederlassen oben ist jemand da oben ist
jemand da oben ist jemand da daher kommt
hier rein der kommt hier rein der
vollidiot er kommt hier rein union edu
kommt heute noch zwei minuten packen wir
das oder nicht
bei der kommentare ich bleibe einfach
hier
ich konnte doch nicht prozent aber nach
nein ich dachte da könnte ich mir so ein
buch geben wenn ich da drunter her
laufen und dann springe unter plötzlich
springt jetzt mein ziel irgendwie die
anderen leute unterbringen
hier oben wollte ich eigentlich wieder
hin sondern wäre ich von hier irgendwie
da so drauf gesprungen momente zeigt
euch das eben ich werde von hier so
darüber gesprochen dass ich mich einfach
drauf gestellt dass er schuldig weil da
hinten auch schon irgendwo andere bieten
blöcke b und spaß wenn ich mit
blumentopf wert wird mich einfach
wirklich irgendwie hier zu stellen oder
hier in einem blumentopf erstmal so gut
bedient und ich war zum dritten block
bekommen obwohl ich eigentlich kein
anderes wollte er oder da auch für
blumentopf commerce im blumentopf von da
nicht dass wir auch richtig gut aber ich
war kein blumentopf diesem app ist
ausgelegt für blumentöpfe überall so
blöd verraten
wir haben verloren so wie immer aber gut
freuen ich habe wenigstens die erste
runde gewonnen
edwards war nicht viel zu beigetragen
aber com crafter kann ich nach der
runden ins greenpeace aber natürlich kag
wurst ach nee er hat vogel krank
okay das war's mit minecraft triple part
2 wenn ihr noch eine weitere folge
minecraft witte wollte dann zeigt es mir
und gibt einen daumen hoch und schreibe
es in die kommentare und dann sehen wir
uns in der nächsten folge wieder weil
das ganze sehr viel arbeit zu bearbeiten
sehr viel arbeit war egal